yeah yeah uh happy Monday
everybody so last Friday with the help
of journalist Matt taibi Elon Musk
revealed how facts were suppressed on
Twitter in order to sway an election it
was fun to witness watching the left
losing it like a porta potty in a
category five
it was everywhere
and everything you assume might be true
about something well it turned out to be
true all along and unless you're
watching me work out that almost never
happens
but we found out that Twitter was indeed
manipulated by liberals to amplify and
suppress information in order to control
public opinion and ultimately an
election it wasn't a Smoking Gun it was
a flaming howitzer
so where are those who say this is worse
than Watergate you know like this
jackass
this is far worse than Watergate why
this is worse than Watergate is worse
than Watergate this in some ways is
worse than Watergate I keep getting
asked are there Echoes of Watergate in
this and there are ah shut up
finally you have the real election
tampering and this dope is like our
president's teeth after 8 pm
nowhere to be found
and now musk is pulling the curtain back
and the truth is as plain as the
powder-covered nose on Hunter's face
and yes we're covering it like we always
covered it before but everywhere else
the story disappeared like a half gallon
tub of potato salad and Anna Navarro's
fridge
I moved on from Brian
solid I don't prove Greger
just like the story did when it first
appeared remember it disappeared too it
seems that the more the truth bubbles up
the more the media buries it but with
elon's Twitter you see everything even
the most honest back and forth between
an ex-wife and husband ever
here is one of musk's angry Ex-Wives
tweeting at him like well an angry
ex-wife quote so let me get this
straight we are now supposed to step
into the marketplace of ideas to debate
and discuss if Hitler behaved poorly or
if women should be raped and locked in
cages because these are conversations
the culture needs to be having and she
goes on and on from there
so what's musk the ex-husband's response
[Laughter]
it's amazing how a single Emoji can can
convey everything
if you translated that face it would say
now do you see why I nearly sawed off my
hand to remove my wedding ring
this is why emojis rule imagine how much
faster any legal proceeding would be if
both sides just submitted a single Emoji
the whole Amber Heard versus Johnny Depp
trial could have been reduced to this
it's a long way for a poop joke
but I'll go there now on Twitter the
only suppression comes from those
a-holes who are always suppressing the
news from the beginning they hogged the
mic and turned Twitter into their
personal karaoke party and now they've
been exposed and trashing the
whistleblowers for blowing the whistle
on them you have the media going after
taibi for acting as the conduit that
exposes their bias seriously how dare he
act like a journalist and like Mindless
little worker bees they're buzzing used
all the same words here's a quick
example a Dem pulster tweets that
taibi's quote doing PR for the richest
person in the world which sounds just
like a tweet from NBC's Ben Collins who
said taibi's Throwing It All Away to do
PR work for the richest person in the
world
now look at all of these and almost
entirely identical tweets from Blue
Checkers in the media
you always knew this to be true it's
like they all called each other and
asked what are you wearing to the party
tonight or in this case I should say
funeral because musk is killing the old
media with absolute daylight you can see
it so now our journalists are no more
than Bots that vomit spam designed to
overwhelm people into thinking there's
more of them than there are of you it's
similar to Movie Makers using CGI to
shoot a scene that involves a crowd shot
of 500 000 people it's easier and
cheaper than hiring 500 000 real humans
except that here these aren't Bots these
are reporters in theory humans
but in reality there is programmed and
predictable as a Roomba with a busted
wheel
except they spread dirt instead of
cleaning it up
and their only defense is built on one
sentence cut and pasted from who knows
where who gave it to him but at least
they admit that the story happened I
mean good luck finding this story in the
New York Times or on CNN you'd have a
better chance of finding a picture of me
in a heart-shaped frame on Chris
Wallace's nightstand
I thought we ended amicably but he
doesn't
so much for the middle ground CNN so
what's this all mean well something's
happening when the hive mind of the
media reacts like this it's because
someone kicked their nest and they're
buzzing mad they lost control of the
spigot of information and that means
they can no longer suppress truth while
amplifying hoaxes like they used to do
before they would bury real things from
crime to coveted Origins while
amplifying false divisive crap pitting
blacks against whites gaze against
straights Rich against poor but their
powerful friends breaking the law those
stories vanish like a tray of cannolis
and James corden's dressing room
and now Twitter has pulled the
crap-stained rug out from under them and
what do they do they turn on the one
journalist who's doing their job for
them it's kind of amazing reporters
turning on reporters for reporting
Ben Collins of NBC called that taivi a
hack for doing the work that Ben Collins
won't do like Matt's a scab during a
strike but that's the thing they're not
on strike they're still getting paid to
report the news and not just the news
they are told to by the White House or
just the news that they agree with it's
all the news you idiots and that scares
them and with musk in charge they should
be
welcome
tonight's guests
she's so bubbly we're handing out Tums
to the audience outnumbered co-host
Emily compagno
[Applause]
he's a political Maven who enjoys
misbehaving vice president of public
relations for Z Labs Chris Barron
[Applause]
he was the inspiration for pepper spray
after writer and comedian Jamie lissow
and she's only a phone call away if you
dial the psych ward Fox News contributor
captain
Emily you look quite green tonight is
that for any special reason
I thought it was festive and we're in
the holidays
I thought I might go somewhere
interesting but apparently enough about
this it's okay we'll move on I'm Amazed
by the cut and pasting on Twitter like I
get it like we already knew about the
hunter Biden stuff I'm hoping the story
crosses over into a world where people
don't know about it but the fact that
all these people like basically cut and
pasted it tells you everything you knew
about the media the robots they are and
they demonstrate and they are
demonstrating right now that if you dare
to be a free thinker if you dare to
think for yourself ever if you are not
in lockstep you are absolutely
annihilated you are Cannibal and I find
what's so interesting about this too is
in light of that demonstration that we
knew that it was this toxic swamp we
knew that it was accessible right that's
why a lot of us aren't on it because 90
of that noise is coming from 10 of those
rabid users and what happens now as Elon
Musk has laid bare the censorship the
absolute suppression of real information
that Americans needed to know all that
is happening is an absolute full frontal
Howitzer Laden assault on the
journalists meanwhile sitting next to
them is that putrid carcass of the
actual contents that are laid bare I
argue that it is worse than Watergate or
at least on par because what we are
learning what was in Contents means that
there is a question of conflict of
interest of the commander-in-chief of
the White House and has been for quite
some time involving many foreign powers
and I'm not drawing some conclusion but
the questions are there and yet this
media totally covered it up and that
collusion we've seen rampant in this
administration every day since and by
the way what I think is so interesting
I've talked to this about this before
with you guys that the protection
Twitter and social media platforms enjoy
from any type of legal liability as to
that content is that oh we don't touch
it at all right we just host it but now
they clearly touch it and they morph it
and they change it and they suppress it
so they're going to be on the hook for I
think a lot of liability including to
their shareholders they were definitely
touching it
laughs
don't touch it
Jamie uh some say your marriage was
worse than Watergate
um
do you think do you think emojis could
have helped you there have you Converse
less with words and more with primitive
images from your phone you might still
have a family
I was thinking about that as the as
you're doing the mall because I was like
man I haven't seen someone ignore a
laptop like that since my wife came home
early
um
[Applause]
those that the pollsters all that was
correct one of them was in a hurry and
they just tweeted copy and paste yes
um yes I think well I was reading it was
saying like we didn't get some of the
suppression we didn't get some of Hunter
Biden's like pornographic tweets we have
to ask ourselves do we really want to
see more Hunter Biden Point yes yes
um don't even finish the sentence yes we
do at all because it's always him and
it's like these hot girls and they're on
water slides no one has clothes on my
favorite Hunter Biden picks the ones
where he's the photographer yes
why does in my last like why does it
matter why does it matter that these got
out have you ever gone like man we
really thought he was a good guy until
the 12th time we saw him doing cocaine
yes like why does it matter and this
guy's like the greatest life ever by the
way I read recently his allowance is now
ten thousand dollars a week the 100
doesn't have to do anything can you
imagine Hunter's a home and Joe's there
and he goes dad can I get my allowance
and he gives him them ten thousand
dollars then Hunter leaves the room he
comes back and he goes Dad could I get
my allowance
ten thousand dollars
[Applause]
nicely done nicely done
Chris welcome to the show it's good to
be back it's good to see you back and
you're back
so anyway what was your take on the
Friday's uh uh events here's my take
five years of the Legacy Media telling
us that a couple hundred thousand
dollars in Russian Facebook ads made
Trump an illegitimate president like
CNN's doing stakeouts wall to wall
coverage showing up at old lady's house
grandma's house like did you know you're
part of a Russian plot Bob no proof
whatsoever that this had any impact
whatsoever on the election we have polls
that show that people would have voted
differently had they known about the
hunter Biden scandal and here we have
not just like some you know somebody
went and bought some ads here we have
direct connections between the Biden
campaign and by the way between
Democrats in government we're now
talking about a question they're always
like it's not the first amendment
individual it's not as the government oh
here we actually have we actually have
Sitting members of the House and Senate
working with Twitter to manipulate an
election and by the way people can say
what they want about Trump and they can
get all worked up about his mean tweets
or mean truths whatever they are now but
the fact is he right he's right this
election was rigged and Twitter was part
of rigging this election and we ought to
have a serious conversation about how do
we prevent this again and for every
Lefty out there who says I don't have
any problem with this good because when
Ron DeSantis and Donald Trump are
working with Elon Musk to suppress
information that they don't like we'll
see how much you love it then exactly
well put
cat you know what's funny we may we made
fun of every time every day when Trump
was President something was worse than
Watergate right and like and and how we
are actually dealing with this and how
people who aren't on CNN and msnb we
actually treated responsibly we're like
looking through this we admit we've
known this stuff we are like we we know
that we we know this is terrible but we
also like are we've learned enough that
it's it may not have any effect because
the media is still gonna they're already
burying it they're actually going on the
offensive against Elon Musk and saying
all the hate speech is worse and all
this hate speech is all Elon musk's
faults and I'm just super old school
where I think that the hate speech is
the fault of the person who said the
speech because I used to learn about
this stuff in school like subject and
predicate yes like we did learn
something interesting though this is
something that uh about the FBI alerting
Twitter about how what is called hacked
and leaked yeah stuff and that's I don't
think I knew that or maybe I did know
that and I just forgot from all the
drinking but but yeah FBI called ahead
just to make Twitter aware of hack and
leak operation and they met with Twitter
weekly on that so that's kind of that's
got to be investigated that's another
part of the of the rigging you have the
FBI you have you have all of this Intel
all the remember the 51 people you had
Brennan you had Clapper all these people
pushing this and by the way none of
these people have ever apologized none
of them have ever even said we got it
wrong yeah we're sorry yes I don't need
an apology
well maybe I do
I accept your apology somebody just
apologized to me at home yeah see hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else